how'd you find data there was a tear in
the dark world when she was created so I
escaped the thing in me is drawn to dark
matter the way your GPS rides my car so
you're saying it is made of the same
stuff at the dark old yeah and the rider
wants to send them both back to where
they came from I hope that means hell
hell this relative mentions space
planets it's all connected plenty of
them qualify as hell the earth is just
one territory in the war that's been
going on forever yeah I have to get this
book someplace safe keep an eye on my
brother
the Gateway film is ready donate learn a
few things that you saw me last
I don't envy you
I was gonna say the same be here
[Music]
ghostrider I've come to bargain so we
got to talk about that agents of shield
finale and I'll explain what's going on
with season five and Inhumans just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet there's a spider-man
giveaway that's going on right now for
the action figures all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so I know there's so many
questions about what happened during the
finale with the Ghost Rider character
where did he go where it is Phil Coulson
end up at the end of the episode what
happened with ADA and what is this giant
intergalactic interdimensional war that
Ghost Rider was teasing so that's the
reason why I included that clip probably
the most important thing for the next
season in what's coming on agents of
shield the idea that your earth is just
one earth in many in you're part of a
conflict that's been going on for all of
eternity and that's nothing to say about
what's going on with the Inhumans TV
show which is coming this fall as well
as what happened with them getting rid
of ADA in this episode is she truly gone
like she turned to ash it seems like
she's gone but then Radcliffe just
vanishes midair while he's raising his
drink glass up like somebody teleported
in and then teleported them out before
he could take a drink I'm just going to
talk about the stuff in this episode
first then I'll talk about season five
then I'll talk about Inhumans crossover
because we have been confirmed for a
full season of agents of shield season
five that's 22 episodes total so we got
to say it to the best moments in this
episode or one Ghost Rider dayz team up
then Coulson walks in and says oh I
missed it I missed it the two of you
together like we know Coulson is a big
collector he reads comics that's what
the Captain America Trading Cards were
all about he's the super nerd of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so he just
geeks out when he sees Ghost Rider and
Daisy teaming up but then to top it off
the spirit of vengeance passes into
Coulson so they can trick ADA and kill
her writer Coulson right on so we just
love the fact that they're able to let
the Coulson character have all the fun
and that's kind of the way it's been in
all the Marvel movies he's the guy that
gets to interact with all the different
Avengers he gets to geek out over his
hero Captain America
I watched you while you sleep probably
still one of the funniest lines in any
Avengers movie ever but really the big
twist of the episode was in that there's
a bargain that he
made as part of him taking the rider
into him so they could kill ADA you know
the deal you made I don't envy you so
there's like this bargain that Coulson
made in order to make that switch happen
and we don't know what that is but
presumably it has something to do with
him winding up in outer space here so I
am going to do like a season five teaser
video where I'll explain a little bit
about what's going on here but what
they're teasing is is that they're
pushing into this story that Ghost Rider
teases the war that's been going on for
an eternity that goes way beyond planet
Earth that sort of links up with Ghost
Rider using his sling ring technique
with the chain if you guys didn't spot
that that's a big Doctor Strange thing
they use the sling ring on that movie to
open portals to wherever they want to go
they can go between dimensions they can
go between places on earth it could be
as casual or as big as they want and now
Ghost Rider has learned to do it in the
time that he's been gone
using his he'll chain so there's a lot
of Doctor Strange stuff that they're
pushing into is an extra dimensional
sward stuff so you have a bunch of
different planets all across the
multiverse Ghost Rider looks like he
goes back to the Dark Dimension like it
looks like this rocky plane they just
you know no vegetation just really dark
and gritty the place that he's been this
whole time where he sent his uncle where
he's going to store the Darkhold
so if you don't know what sword is from
the comics it's sort of like a shield
organization but for outer space but the
stuff they're teasing on shield is
multiverse so during Doctor Strange
there's the Dark Dimension where
Dormammu is from Ghost Rider mentions
the dark world which could potentially
be a different place but he says hell is
relative is just one of many planets
each one worse than the next so it's
their way of doing dark dimension
Dormammu type stuff without actually
having to bring Dormammu onto the screen
but Mephisto is probably the likely
candidate if they ever choose to do some
big cosmic entity so yes I do think the
Ghost Rider will return next season they
haven't announced what the official
storyline is going to be what they're
going to call it we just know that
Coulson has been taken by people that
look like they're from Earth that have
crazy technology and he is working as
part of a bargain but he doesn't seem
like he has a gun to his head when he
says time to get to work like he's
working at some big space Factory or
something like that but it all goes back
to that bargain he made with the rider
in his probably
this intergalactic dimensional war the
ghostwriter was teasing so there were a
whole bunch Easter eggs during the
episode they even had some Whedon birth
shout outs because Joss Whedon was the
creator the executive producer of the
show but his brother Jed Whedon and his
wife Marissa tantaran they basically run
the show but they tried to include as
many Joss Whedon jokes as possible so
like they say the ghostwriter got sucked
into a Hellmouth
that's something from the Buffy TV show
but the sword agency in the comics
debuted during Joss Whedon's astonishing
x-men run so sword is also kind of like
a Whedon verse thing - but let me know
in the comments who here wishes that
they would have actually started agents
of shield in this place here you can
understand how they kind of had to work
up to it first they had to explain what
Inhumans were they had to deal with the
Hydra arc because that was a big thing
in the movies they were trying to be as
connected as possible now that we know
who Inhumans are and we know about
Doctor Strange we know about the
multiverse and we know about magic they
can do all the mystical things but you
can see how infinity war is coming it's
an intergalactic universal war that's
going to be coming thanks to Thanos so
they're teasing something on that scale
with agents of shield even though I'm
not expecting shield characters to be in
any of those Avengers movies Ghost
Rider's fair game but right now I think
the shield TV show has claim to him now
when we get to Inhumans that's a
completely different story so just to
explain what's going on with that in the
fall
Inhumans is going to premiere it'll be a
Friday night TV show it'll run for eight
episodes and then after the finale
agents of shield season five will just
take that time slot so shield and in
humans are now Friday night shows the
first Inhumans episodes won't drop till
August that'll be in IMAX and then
they'll air everything on TV it'll be on
the ABC network so the same place you
watch shield right now is where the
Inhumans TV show is going to premiere
there wasn't an humans trailer that they
played this week for the upfront but
they haven't posted that online when
they do all totally do a video for it
they're like yeah it feels very Game of
Thrones II and the Marvel Universal I
was like great I love Game of Thrones
I love Marvel we'll see how this goes
but I feel like Ghost Rider was probably
the best decision that agents of shield
made this year they were totally solid I
feel like they had a lot more fun just
because they knew that it might be their
last season so hopefully now that it's
on Friday nights and it's a little bit
later
in the evening they can be way more
hardcore this is a pretty hardcore
episode so let me know in the comments
what did you think about the episode
what do you think about the series now
what do you want them to do with the
Inhumans TV show there'll be a lot more
inhuman stuff happening this summer
because they'll come to Comic Con
they'll be footage for that there's
still a lot of unanswered questions but
what's going to happen next is is I'll
post my arrow video there'll be an arrow
finale trailer and then I'll post agents
of shield season 5 teaser so just be
sure to check your notifications check
my channel page like my videos tab just
to see when I'm posting stuff you can
click here for my flash trailer and you
can click here for brand new spider-man
homecoming thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight